there's a really disturbing story out
from wisconsin wisconsin school district
a wisconsin school district is providing
sexually explicit books
to third graders the some of the
material teaches students how to use sex
apps these are to eight-year-olds by the
way
now the way this is being provided is
that the
school district is offering students
access to books and information
via an online library that includes
books such as this book is gay by juno
dawson queer by kathy belge and merc
bish and this book is gay by the way
teaches kids how to use grinder which is
a gay sex app
so what what the defenders of this are
going to say is oh they just have access
to it but they're not being assigned
these sorts of books right but
they shouldn't have access they should
that's the point i'm not making an
argument for
banning and burning books explicitly
okay although that sort of practice is
looked unfavorably in both the new
testament
and uh and by plato the
like one of the founders of western
philosophy but i'm not making that
argument okay even though plato famously
called for the burning of his
of his opponent's books my question is
much
more modest should eight-year-olds
really be exposed to everything is a
third grade classroom
really a free marketplace of ideas i
think
the very thought that that would be the
case would have our founding fathers
rolling over
in their graves hey
you we're not allowed to talk so much on
youtube anymore they don't like some of
the things we say
so you've got to make sure that you ring
that bell and you subscribe
because sometimes people do that but
they still don't get the notification so
make sure you do that head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
you can subscribe
to the michael knowles show and you can
order right now
my book the number one national
best-selling
non-new york times listed because
they're a bunch of jerks
speechless controlling words controlling
minds we'll see you next time